alright so maybe you've already sunk
dozens of hours into dark souls 2 and
you're a huge fan of the soul series but
what about those of you who've never
taken the plunge into the infamously
tricky RPG series and want to know what
all the fuss is about well today's just
episode is for you so you can figure out
why dark souls 2 matters just so damn
much it was a few years ago when I
decided to crack into demons souls it
seemed like a good idea merely because I
was fascinated by the game concept and
buzz but it didn't take long till I had
my ass handed to me nevertheless while
dark souls is hard it's a huge mistake
to assume that that's all that the game
offers because in a lot of ways its
influence not only the action RPG genre
but the modern video game medium this is
a factor you guys brought up adamantly
after my gist episode on games that are
harder than dark souls for the outsider
difficulty is too dark souls what butter
is to bread but it's the way that the
developer from software manipulates and
leverages this feature which makes the
series so awesome an obvious reason why
the game is so important is that it's
represented the rebirth of challenge in
gaming dark souls is certainly not the
only hard game on the market or the only
one that's worth throwing your money out
but it deserves recognition for going
against the trend of steadily dumbing
down triple eight games for years that's
a trend I discussed with devs cliffy B
and the guys who made super meat boy a
while back latest diablo its downfall
not only was difficulty which was a
complete and utter breeze it was
mind-numbing lee dull because of how
easy it was when a game is truly
challenging to master your attachment to
it becomes more meaningful the thrill of
threat is a beautiful thing that Hawks
back to pretty much every good horror
game amnesia and early resident evil
games work so well because there's a lot
more at stake every time you encounter
an
me oh [ __ ] what what do you can sees you
I don't know do you think it's the Omega
maybe hey let's talk about this you're
being rash dark souls is successful in
the same way because even though losing
a battle will set you back significantly
the sense of achievement when you
succeed is so much greater dark souls
may be bringing back the enjoyment /
working for your victories but it's in
the first five in game minutes that you
get a feeling for one of the other
really great features the absence of an
overbearing tutorial and a lack of
direction the souls series wants you to
explore and figure things out for
yourself like retro games they want you
to fail and learn and you really will
fail if you're hoping that this will be
like other action games which mostly
hold your hand because Dark Souls would
prefer to push you in the dirt honestly
though if it treated you any different
you wouldn't learn the skills you need
to get through the game because classic
tutorial and suggestive orientating
prompts are stripped the world feels
more immersive and the victory in
discovering tucked away areas is well
and truly your own the lack of any clear
direction is what I loved and hated most
about the legend of zelda majora's mask
but it's a great choice in a game like
this and one which a lot of devs would
shy away from in fear of alienating
gamers ask anybody what's so great about
Dark Souls and I promise they'll pretty
much all tell you one very simple thing
the brutal but completely rewarding
combat the best thing about games with
seriously refined combat systems
particularly action based ones is that
you're punished for making mistakes that
means when you get dealt a huge blow
it's because you screwed up that dodge
or took a nun calculated risk not
because the gameplays flawed or
something glitched out Dark Souls
prevails at tactical and strategic
combat which require players to learn
their enemies leverage their own
strengths and execute everything in a
way that suits the level design the name
of the game here is challenge and the
challenge incorporated into every
element of Dark Souls creates a
substance that breathe air games will
never have difficulty gives enemy
encounters and in-game realm
significance and make
the memorable sure it might be because
you've died 20 times in one area but
it'll also be because the gameplay is
designed to force you to learn a boss's
movement and combat inclinations
subsequently committing that to memory
to succeed dark souls is daring to be
different and staring to be better
instead of alienating gamers in the
process it's found a serious following
hopefully that'll prove to other devs
that this kind of game can and will
succeed last week I talked to you guys
about how diablo 3 is now totally worth
it again since reaper of souls has come
out and you have an awful lot to say
about it a bunch of you is still pretty
upset that there's no offline mode and
while others reckon dilute improvements
are great it just wasn't enough for you
to get back into the game be sure to let
me know in the comments or on my twitter
why you reckon dark souls is a winner or
not and i will see you again next week